سيارات الأجرة الطائرة هذه هي بعض
النقاط البارزة في معرضنا ، فليس
في غضون عشر سنوات ، ولكن في نهاية
العام المقبل سيتم تسويقها
في أماكن مثل دبي وسنغافورة أيضًا في
ألمانيا في بعض المدن ، لذا فهي مجرد
ظاهرة لأن هذا سيحدث
ثورة  الوقت الذي نتحرك فيه بالطريقة التي
نتحرك فيها وسيؤدي ذلك إلى زيادة الازدحام في المدن
أيضًا لأنه يمكننا بسهولة تامة
استخدام المجال الجوي بعد ذلك بكثير
بالطبع بعض التحديات المتبقية ولكن
الجانب الأكثر روعة في ذلك ليس
فقط للأثرياء والأثرياء لأنه
مرة واحدة  تصبح مستقلة وستتكلف
فقط نفس تكلفة سيارة الأجرة في الوقت الحاضر ،
لذا سيكون حقًا في متناول الكثير
من الناس وأعتقد أن
قوة مستقبل التكنولوجيا الخضراء هي أنها
قادمة الآن ولم تعد حل وسط
بعد الآن  مثلك تحتاج إلى
التنازل عن شيء ما لأنه رائع ، إنه
مستدام ، إنه أرخص في معظم الأحيان ،
لذا فهو موجود لتبقى
وأعتقد حقًا أن نتعلم جميعًا أن
نتقبله لأنه  إنها
قوية جدًا أيضًا ولدينا تأثير كبير جدًا